Let's go next to our caller from the five
Oh five area code. Who's calling today from
five Oh five.
Hey David, this is Isaiah from Albuquerque.
Hey, um, I actually just had a quick question,
um, in regards to, um, my prediction or, and
definitely hope is that burning takes, uh,
the primary, but if he ends up going up against
Trump and the general election and ended up
losing, I'm curious how um, progressive might
refocus strategically future elections or
how do you think something like that would
affect political strategy for the progressive
left?
Well, we talked about this on a segment a
few weeks ago where we, I laid out how, if
you look at the, if you kind of game out the
different scenarios, Bernie is the nominee
and wins. Bernie is the nominee and loses
a centrist is the nominee and wins, or a centrist
is the nominee and loses. If Bernie is the
nominee and loses to Trump, not only will
Republicans say this is a rejection of left
social democracy, even the centrist democratic
party will say, this has been a rejection
of centrist of a, of a left social democracy,
and we should never again elect someone like
Bernie to be the nominee in the first place.
So I think that until it happens, we're not
really going to know the repercussions, but
there is no doubt that, so if Bernie fails
to be the nominee, then you will have the
democratic party saying, see, we told you
that those ideas weren't viable to be the
nominee. If Bernie is the nominee but loses
the Trump, they will say, see, we told you
that even if the democratic party selected
Bernie as the nominee, that these ideas would
lose to Trump nationally. So no matter what,
they are going to react in that way. The specific
way in which it will happen is we were sort
of in a wait and see on that.
Definitely. Do you, do you believe that it
would show any sort of, I'm out of touch,
miss, so to speak from the left, if Bernie
loses in the sense that um, there's a real
big, um, platform that it's grassroots diverse
and it's really what the people want as far
as policy go. Um, but maybe it would just
be enlightening in some sense and expose some,
um, sort of misunderstandings that we might
have. The U S populace as a whole thing you
have to remember
is when half the country doesn't vote, you
can have policies that are popular with 75%
of the country, but based on who chooses to
go out and vote for and against the policies,
they might only be represented say 45% at
the ballot box, even though they might represent
75% of all Americans, and so it's tricky and
dangerous too.
Extract
[inaudible] too much from that because half
the country or 45% of the country doesn't
even vote.
Definitely. Yeah, that's a fair point. Yeah,
unfortunately, but well, thank you for taking
my questions, David. I'm a big thing.
Thanks Isaiah. Alcove to hear from you again.
Let's take a quick break. We are going to
take more calls right after this short break,
so if you're currently holding, please don't
hang up because we are getting right back
to the calls momentarily.